tens of thousands of protesters show
their support for the ethiopian
government
[Music]
organized by the city's administration
it's also meant to lend support to the
armed forces in their war against the
tigray rebels and their allies famous
singer tariq angesi was invited to sing
in praise of ethiopia's military and
took the opportunity to call for peace
i was in the battleground when i was
told the battle was against my brother i
turned back
let the young people not be sent instead
let's send our elders negotiation is
better with guns we bring no solution
it's enough
the ethiopian government has called the
fight against the tigray rebels an
existential war
prime minister abi ahmed who won the
nobel peace prize two years ago has
vowed to bury his enemies abi also
declared a nationwide state of emergency
that allows any armed citizen of
military age to be conscripted
the military has also asked veterans to
re-enlist
thousands of civilians have since joined
the war
despite the state of emergency declared
by the government there is calm on the
streets of alisaba traffic on the city's
main roads remain busy as residents go
about their daily business
but there is an unusually heavy police
presence with officers conducting random
security and identity checks
i don't feel any different since the
state of emergency was declared
commodity prices have not changed much
after entering the state of emergency my
business has not changed much and i can
see my customers coming to buy things
every day just as before i'm not too
worried about what will happen in the
future but i hope that our country will
have peace soon
but not everyone is confident the u.s
embassy in addis ababa ordered the
departure of its non-essential diplomats
on saturday
a day after advising all u.s citizens to
leave ethiopia as soon as possible
and several other embassies including
those of saudi arabia canada sweden and
norway have now done the same
muhammad al jazeera
by ethiopia